Well, I am one of the directors of science
[at NASA], and my specialty is communications.
There's the idea that a mission ends when
you return the data, when you make the discoveries,
when the scientists publish their papers.
To me, the mission doesn’t end until you
have some sort of public involvement, until
you have some sort of public buy-in.
I think that’s as important as any other
part of the mission.
I’ve been trying to tell people for years
that a communications team on a mission is
just like having your crack team of electrical
engineers or your best computer programmers.
You need to have people that really understand
communications well.
And it helps—I mean, in my case I started
out as a research astrophysicist and so I
understand a lot of the topics as well.
But I do communications now at NASA.
And as far as why NASA is important, I think
this is one of these things that people have
no idea: We run, at the moment, 108 science
missions.
Those are mostly spacecraft.
Some of them are on balloons or sounding rockets
or on the space station.
Some of them are on the earth.
We have people embedded with the Sami reindeer
herders trying to understand how climate change
is changing the migration of reindeer herds.
I mean it’s amazing that NASA is all over.
Everything from the disaster mitigation from
all of those hurricanes—we actually sent
staff to Puerto Rico when FEMA was overwhelmed,
they had been setting up communication centers.
I mean everything from determining what set
off the Big Bang to where those wildfires
are going to be spreading to in southern California.
We have 108 missions and I’ve never seen
any organization operate more efficiently.
I’ve never worked with more brilliant people.
I think people often don't understand what
the real value is as far as blue sky research,
you know.
People talk about spinoffs and people joke
about things like Velcro and Tang.
I mean those are jokes, but the more intelligent
people might notice things like microprocessors
started at NASA.
Cell phones.
The reason you have computers, the reason
the United States was poised to lead the computer
revolution was because of the Apollo program.
But all those kind of fall flat, to tell you
the truth.
I think that people don’t understand.
It was a NASA satellite doing research just
out of curiosity to see what gases were in
the atmosphere that discovered that the ozone
hole was being depleted in the 1980s.
And the NASA scientists with a number of university
scientists went running to the U.N. and said,
“If we don’t do something, we are literally
going to destroy the planet.”
And they actually got the Montreal Protocol
signed.
They actually made treaties.
They banned these chemicals that were depleting
our ozone layer.
And we’ve since done atmospheric models
that show that we would have actually destroyed
the ozone layer, had we done nothing, by the
year 2060, which, if not in my lifetime, is
probably in our children’s lifetime.
And basically, that would have destroyed agriculture.
Crops would have failed all over the world.
You couldn’t have livestock outside.
People couldn’t have lived outside.
We very nearly destroyed civilization, and
your grandchildren would have lived through
that.
And so when people talk about what’s the
best NASA spinoff, you know, what's the worth
of blue sky research where you don’t understand
where it’s going to lead?
The best spinoff I know of is grandchildren.